i absolutely love legion
um and uh so i'm curious when you
pitched it to fx did you at the
beginning did you know it was going to
be three years was that your goal
or were you sort of like i have this
idea let's see where it goes
i kind of knew it was going to be three
acts i can say
that i i knew that
in telling a story about
mental illness let's say that that that
starts with
with david where he was which is he he'd
attempted suicide he was in the hospital
that there's a kind of journey um
unfortunately that's a cycle right you
go from
from your lowest point to
hospitalization to
taking your meds to stabilizing
to thinking i don't need these meds
anymore to going off your meds
to going down the rabbit hole and then
back
you know what i mean so so that felt to
me
like if you substitute
love story for meds right that
you know david gets out of the hospital
in that first hour
he's in love that love buoys him
he ends up getting to a pla from a place
where he doesn't understand anything
that's going on to a place where he
understands
everything that's going on you know what
i mean and then
unfortunately he's put in this position
by the woman he loves that makes him
betray the woman he loves
the same woman in two different time
periods and that gets him to a point
where he's off his meds
and his decisions are less and less
rational and then he's down at the
bottom and he's either gonna
he's either gonna come all the way back
or that's the end of him and once you
complete that story the only way place
to go is back through that
cycle so that's why it was the three
seasons and i didn't know at the time if
three acts meant three years it could
have meant five
years you know it could have been the
acts more spread out
you know but what i what i learned in
the second season of
legion you know when i was wrestling
with a lot of episodes that were really
long
was that this show doesn't want to be
long you know i would reach a point
in an episode of legion when i was
editing it where i would think this
episode wants to be over
right now you know like even if there
was more great stuff to come
it's a lot to absorb
you know there's a lot of sort of more
surreal images the fact that your brain
has to work to kind of figure out
what where you are and what things mean
and you can only ask the audience to do
that for
so long before it starts being work and
not fun
you know and it felt the same with the
overall story which is i suppose we
could have kept going
but it felt like better to make a
complete statement
that you want more of than to make
something
where people go i think that's enough of
that sure
the uh i loved the ending of the series
did you always know that was the ending
from the beginning or did you find it
along the way
uh i found it along the way i guess i
didn't know from the beginning that
literally
the first and the last images would be
the same
um but um but it did have a kind of
you know poetry to it it felt like when
i when i
figured it out and and you know
it's probably something i figured out in
season two
um i think of where this journey
was going to have to end uh the
the ratings were never awesome on legion
but it was a critical darling everyone
who reviewed it
i mean it's you know it got great
reviews
do you think it was those reviews and
the buzz
that sort of helped keep it on the air
because it was you know it never got
like 10 million people watching or
you know whatever the you know some huge
hit
yeah well i think so i mean obviously i
have a larger relationship with fx and
and you know we certainly
had conversations about it i mean
the two things that happen when a thing
isn't
successful ratings wise is do you have
to talk about
is it time to end this and also are you
spending too much on it
um you know neither of those
conversations we we really had
i think that they were not unhappy when
i said the third year is the last year
um but i think they were hugely proud of
the show and and
you know critically it's critical
reception
and and just its perception you know
there are a lot of superhero shows
um that um
you know as as good as they are often
come down to
good versus evil might makes right and
we were doing something else and i i
think they really appreciated kind of
owning that
something else um now
if i were making that show now in a
disney universe
would the with the budget
would they be forced to end it early
they might
you know it's a different they're under
different management and and it's a
different
it's a different world but luckily i got
it in under the wire
uh one of the things that i loved about
the way you told the story was the
visuals
and uh just the where the camera was and
the in-camera effects
and the narrative style the choices you
made um
can you sort of talk about the
difficulty in i think you had 21 days to
make your pilot
and the regular show was like a eight
day shoot how the hell did you pull that
off
on the schedule you had well
you know i would always tell the
directors let the simple things be
simple
right because some people came into
legion thinking that every shot every
angle every moment had to have some
gimmick to it
it was like well that's not really good
storytelling i mean
the reality is if you have good
production designing great actors
like most of the time the camera doesn't
need to do that much
you know what i mean and and there are
scenes which are emotional or character
driven or information driven in which
you know the most important thing in the
scene is that you get the information
so i don't want the camera doing this
crazy thing
you're michael bay spin you know like
that's that's not going to help me
convey
anything you know the other thing is
that i never wrote
any visual gag that i hadn't thought
through how to pull off
you know so a lot of what i did
on legion was to sit with the directors
and go you're over
complicating it like literally i want
something
that you could do with a sleight of hand
episode
you know where david was going into
everybody's minds and he went into gene
smart's mind and it was the sort of like
early video game with the text you know
and
and you know like you you are in a cave
and they would type like we walked down
the cave and everything and there was
this moment where the
you know where where he typed jump and
the moment he had entered
the ceiling dropped and and hit them and
and
it's like that's just a very easy thing
to do in a black
void you don't you don't have to to get
stunt people involved you know so a lot
of what i did was
to say the
you know cinema is already a trick like
it's it's not you don't have to go as
crazy
and and go full ilm on this you can
simplify it
so you know but but it really you know
you have to have bold iconic images and
and one of the mandates that i had in in
crafting each episode was that
there had to be these moments that when
you saw the trailer for next week you're
like
how did they do that we have to watch
that one